uh now we're joined by former house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy he's calling
right now for bold action from America
in response to the MOs Terror attacks in
Israel that would include a fullscale
effort to rescue American hostages
complete support for our Ally Israel new
measures to confront Iran and what we've
been calling on this show this new axis
of Evil and a commitment to secure our
open borders and condemnation of all the
anti-Semitism within the US uh
Congressman I got to ask you you know
how do we rescue these American South
hostage what price will be paid for the
killing of Americans here and the
killing of the Israelis here uh what
will we do to provide support for our
our best ally in the region uh and what
confrontation are they willing to engage
in in terms of Iran because it seems all
they want to do is give them billions of
dollars you're 100% right the first
thing you have to do is go back to what
we had in the last Administration we no
long longer pay for Americans for the
ransom to bring them home we simply tell
them if they harm them we will kill you
we should make sure there are 11
Americans dead now and he's having a
barbecue we've got hostages sitting
there but the other thing we need to do
yes we should freeze that six billion
but the part that you don't quite
understand is the 60 billion he's
allowed when Biden came into office Iran
was only producing 400,000 barrels of
oil today now they're producing 3
million there are sanctions against that
but he does not enforce it enforce those
you know what is the foreign currency
reserves are for Iran when Biden took
office it was only four billion it's now
up to 70 he's made Iran wealthy he's
made him more secure and able to fund
more terrorism for them to look at
anybody in the face to say that Iran was
not involved in this that's like saying
our border is secure nobody believes
them we should make sure and pass right
now make sure they have enough missiles
for the Iron Dome because What's
Happening Here is they're trying to
overwhelm I've been to these locations
many times I've been to those caboots
that I see them massacring these
innocent civilians th those first
missiles were probably a lot of dumb
Rockets but what they want to do is wear
out the Iron Dome and then send the
Precision guiding ones we should make
sure that we're going to provide any
ammunition we store it there in Israel
provide it to them now and everybody has
to say one complete thing this isn't
about weak ing Hamas this is about
destroying Hamas and we will stand
shoulders toh shoulder and anybody else
that gets into this conflict we will
make sure you fail too you've got to be
clear and we've got to bring everybody
else around the world combined with us
they were attacked as you say 35,000
what would we do what would we expect
from our friends to do with us let me
ask you Mr you know just up till last
week you were the speaker of the house
um I know the issue has come up whether
or not there are still members that
would like you to take that position
back uh I know there's a contest you
have candidates stated candidate Steve
scal and Jim Jordan uh how important is
it for the Republican conference to get
this this decision made quickly it's
very important but we got to get it
right you you cannot have 96% of your
conference one place and eight people
partner with the Democrats and Nancy
Pelosi to dictate who our speaker is
think for one moment Sean
what if we followed Gates's advice and
shut the government down and the
government would be shut down right now
where our 30,000 troops in the Middle
East wondering if they're going to get
paid are they're sitting on that Strike
Team going with the aircraft carrier
wondering if their family is going to
make their rent why we're telling them
no they can't be paid you know what if I
have to lose the speakership to make
sure our troops get paid especially in a
time like this then I'm going to take
that fight because I'm always going to
stand with Americans first but another
thing that really concerns me and here
here the anti-Semitism that continues to
grow remember what Omar said about 9/11
some people did something that day I
wonder if she says that now or what TB
is doing right now but why is Biden and
hakeim Jeff allowing them to speak for
the Democratic party when they asked
hakee Jeff's spokesperson about it you
know what they said no comment that's
not leadership not right now why we have
this whole new axis of Evil from Iran
Russia and China this looks a lot like
the 1930s and I don't want to be on the
wrong side of History if the president
wants to put a lid on it I'm going to
speak out and lay out a five-point plan
what we should do to make sure the world
is safe and what we should do to make
sure America's stronger and the world is
a safer place to live Kevin McCarthy
will Republicans have a speaker by weeks
in I believe we will the two gentlemen
running I have the capability of putting
it together and I look forward to having
that debate tomorrow night all right
Kevin McCarthy thank you tonight for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else